prochain premier ministre qui succèdera
edouard philippe devra choisir un
gouvernement qui devra être validé par
le président et le conseil des ministres
de ce matin ayant été annulée le
prochain n'aura lieu que mercredi
prochain donc on en saura un peu plus
sur les prochaines péripéties à venir
dans le monde politique pour l'instant
on est encore en train d'attendre
on attend alors qu'un priori un tapis
rouge a été déroulé du côté de matignon
beaucoup de noms circulent pour
remplacer edouard philippe qui seraient
susceptibles d'incarner la dernière
partie du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
oui effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison un tapis rouge vient d'être
déroulé et deux micros ont été installés
comme on me l'a indiqué alors parmi les
noms qui circulent sur les réseaux
sociaux et autour du palais de l'elysée
parmi les personnes qui étaient déjà
présentes au gouvernement et qui serait
pressenti pour succéder à edward
philippe on a par exemple bruno le maire
gérald darmanin ou encore florence parly
ou jean yves le drian c'est selon à
sondages et la publier il ya quelques
jours et puis il ya aussi des noms qui
sont issus de la vie civile qui n'ont
pas fait partie du gouvernement je pense
notamment à laurence tubiana qui faisait
partie de la convention sur le climat ou
encore pascal canfin l'ancien président
de wwf france et qui occupe actuellement
une place d'eurodéputés qui s'occupe de
la convention sur le climat au parlement
européen alors il ya quelques jours il
avait annoncé chez nos confrères de
france info qu'on ne lui avait pas
proposé le ministère de l'écologie mais
que cela peut-être pourrait se produire
mais que pour l'instant il était très
bien là où il est et voilà pour les noms
qui pourraient éventuellement succéder à
edward philippe qui lui va retourner
décidément dans son fief du havre où le
prochain conseil municipal aura lieu
dimanche à 10 heures
kirill c'est la démission du
gouvernement qui a remis ce matin
edouard philippe à emmanuel macron alors
qu'ils pourraient perdre son
portefeuille ministériel
eh bien écoutez qui dit démission dit
départ évidemment et parmi ceux qui
pourraient partir on pense évidemment en
premier lieu à christophe castaner dont
la cote de popularité n'est pas au beau
fixe après presque deux ans de crise des
gilets jaunes on sait que l'actuel le
ministre de l'intérieur ne fait pas du
tout l'unanimité au sein des français
n'ont peut-être un prochain départ et
puis peut-être aussi nicole belloubet
avec sa loi sur la presse plutôt
controversé qui n'a pas fait l'unanimité
non plus cela reste à voir
on en saura un peu plus sur toutes ces
péripéties à venir au cours de la
journée et dans les jours qui suivent
merci à kirill kotick of en direct donc
du palais de l'elysée de l'hôtel de
matignon puisque les deux lieux de
pouvoir ne sont pas très loin l'un de
l'autre
du côté du centre de paris resté avec
nous et évidemment c'est quelque chose
se passe n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir
kirill kotick l'ofs
après trois ans à matignon edouard
philippe
devrait donc rejoindre son fief du havre
où il a été réélu maire dimanche dernier
retour sur son bilan au sein du
gouvernement avec les - hôpital c'est un
nouveau souffle pour le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron le revers subi par la
république en marche aux élections
municipales a convaincu le président de
la nécessité de remanier son
gouvernement
ils se séparent donc de son premier
ministre à deux ans de la fin de son
mandat
l'occasion d'un nouveau départ pour
edouard philippe qui a multiplié les
déplacements ces dernières semaines
entre l'elysée la cité normande
le locataire de matignon avait laissé
entrevoir la possibilité d'un éventuel
départ du gouvernement pour reprendre sa
casquette de maire mon objectif c'est
d'être maire du havre vite ça peut
arriver très vite si ça arrive très vite
ça sera très bien
l'épidémie de coronavirus a poussé
emmanuel macron à ouvrir le troisième
acte de son quinquennat la crise
sanitaire a fragilisé la majorité
déstabilisé par les tensions sociales
permanente et avec l'arrivée de la crise
économique le président a dû poser un
acte fort en se séparant de son homme
providentiel pour reprendre la main au
cours de ces trois dernières années
edouard philippe a maintes fois servi de
bouclier à emmanuel macron notamment
face aux mouvements des gilet jaune
le premier ministre avait alors défendu
la réponse ferme de l'exécutif face aux
débordements lors des manifestations à
paris
on va utiliser tous les moyens de droit
et toutes les mobilités tout le
dynamisme dont nous pouvons faire preuve
pour répondre à ceux qui viennent mettre
en cause les forces de l'ordre mettre en
cause la propriété privée vous
m'entendez bien nous allons mettre en
voit tous les moyens de droit et tous
les moyens dans la mobilisation dans la
stratégie des forces de l'ordre pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions
apporter une réponse qui ne rendent plus
possible ses actes un recours à la force
présent également dans le processus
législatif le premier ministre avait
engagé la responsabilité du gouvernement
sur la réforme controversée des
retraites en
l'article 49 alinéa 3 a permis
l'adoption du projet en première lecture
avant les élections municipales
mais la crise sanitaire a ensuite amené
emmanuel macron à geler toutes les
réformes conformément à l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la constitution de 1958 et
après en avoir obtenu l'autorisation du
conseil des ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi
alors que c'est la fin du règne des
doigts félipe à la tête du pouvoir
gouvernemental
la cote de confiance du maire du havre
poursuit sa progression avec 51%
d'opinions favorables soit un gain de 13
points depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire durant laquelle il a été très
exposé et on continue de parler de ce
remaniement avec agile casanova
consultant expert en stratégie en
communication
passé notamment par plusieurs ministères
comme celui de l'intérieur par exemple
bonjour gilles casanova merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
rt france vous êtes spécialiste en
communication pourquoi cette annonce
aujourd'hui près d'une semaine après le
probable deuxième tour des élections
municipales
est ce que c'est parce qu'elle les
conseils municipaux dès ce week-end pour
élire les maires sur les tueurs étaient
prévues demain il aura lieu finalement
dimanche à 10 heures nous sommes avec
emmanuel macron en permanence dans le
spectacle la communication c'est le
choix qu'il a faits à l'origine de gérer
le pouvoir politique de gérer sa
carrière politique
de cette façon extraordinairement
spectaculaire cela fait des mois et des
mois que l'on parle du remplacement
d'edouard philippe donc on n'est pas du
tout dans le coup de tonnerre dans un
ciel serein
cela fait des mois que des noms
circulent à peu près toujours les mêmes
qui ne présente guère de caractère de
nouveauté et en même temps ce matin on
annonce soudainement la démission du
premier ministre qui est en fête
traditionnelle après de grandes
sélections nationales mais contrairement
à l'habitude
le communiqué ne précise pas qui est
chargé de former le nouveau gouvernement
donc nous avons là un épisode organisé
de suspense suspension dramatique qui
permet aux nombreuses chaînes de
télévision dont on doit dire qu'elles ne
sont pas éloignés des vues de l'elysée
de se perdre en conjectures sur les
remarquables qualités de tout ce qui
pourrait venir et de celui qui va les
choisir met donc pour répondre
précisément à ma question pourquoi
aujourd'hui cette cette annonce
lorsqu'il devait y avoir un conseil des
ministres et que tenir un conseil des
ministres avec un premier ministre
partant ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens donc
l' annonce a été faite au moment où
c'était d'un point de vue technique le
plus cohérent et surtout cela laisse le
temps pour former gouvernement d'aller
jusqu'à mercredi date du prochain
conseil des ministres
rien ne dit qu'il sera aisé est facile
de former un gouvernement même si ça
fait des mois qu'on y réfléchisse en
haut lieu vous savez ces choses là se
font au dernier moment dans l'urgence
est là que se font les derniers
arbitrages et donc
cette urgence elle peut prendre des
heures de nombreuses heures de plus et
savoir que le conseil des ministres m
ercredi permet d'avoir tout le week end
pour négocier discuter convaincre aussi
parce que ce n'est peut-être pas
extraordinairement facile pour emmanuel
macron d'attirer des personnes autour de
lui dans une situation qui s'annonce
difficile et avec un ou une premier
ministre dont le poids politique
n'apparaitra probablement pas marquant
puisque comme souvent dans ces cas là
pour la seconde
la dernière partie du quinquennat le
président veut un exécutant ou une
exécutante qui lui permettent d'être
directement premier ministre on a perçu
1 des images en direct de l'hôtel de
matignon a gelé casanova avec pour
l'instant une guerre de rapprocher un
devant devant cette cette porte pas de
mouvement dont on sait qu'il y à un
tapis rouge qui a été déroulé qu'il ya
des micros qui ont été installées à
l'intérieur derrière derrière ces murs
est ce que ça veut dire que c'est
imminent vous avez parlé de d'une
urgence
d'un premier ministre qui n'auraient pas
forcément les coudées franches mais qui
pour justement succédé à edouard
philippe ya beaucoup de noms
dernièrement parle de laurence tubiana
ou encore de bruno le maire pourquoi pas
pascal canfin comme l'a dit kirill
kotick of tout à l'heure à voir à la
fois un profil libéral progressiste
sociale et écologiste suite à la vague
verte du week-end dernier
est-ce que ça se trouve est ce qu est la
profondeur de banc nécessaire comme on
dit en football pour pour la république
en marche
non ce qui est nécessaire ce n'est pas
ce dont vous avez fait la liste ça c'est
l'habillage qui sera donnée ensuite et
je peux vous assurer que vos confrères
trouveront que c'est absolument
merveilleusement réussi mais ce qui est
nécessaire c'est une personne qui
accepte d'être purement exécutante et
d'avoir le travail terrible des nombreux
arbitrages quotidien qui se font à
matignon le très nombreux arbitrages
quotidien et qui vont se faire
directement sous la férule de l'elysée
et donc il faut accepter une position
très inconfortable qui ne permettra pas
en retour d'avoir un véritable pouvoir
donc il faut pour cela une personne
diaphane politiquement c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui ne soit pas un leader
politique quelqu'un qui est un profil de
haut fonctionnaire ou deux présentateurs
de télévision
je veux pas critiquer les présentateurs
de télévision bien sûr mais disons que
ce ne sont pas des personnalités
politiques dont l'orientation verte
vous parlez d'un exécutant un
gilles casanova pour que ce poste de
premier ministre mais avec quel cap
politique un remaniement c'est aussi un
changement de cap non à quoi est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre en termes de
politiques à venir on a vu emmanuel
macron s'exprimer dans la presse
quotidienne régionale ce matin parler de
la réforme des retraites avec une
nouvelle concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux tout en conservant
le projet il ya également l'écologie il
ya également le social ou encore le
ségur de la santé quel cap avec cette
fin de quinquennat comme vous le dites
pour cet exécutant selon son nouveau
tracé mythique
il n'a absolument aucune intention de
dédier en rien du cap qu'il a mis en
oeuvre depuis trois ans si vous
l'écoutez avec attention
régulièrement il dit que plus rien ne
sera comme avant
puis il dit qu'il n'a en rien à renier
ce qu'il a fait depuis trois ans et que
ce qu'il va faire se place dans la
plaine continuité je crois que c'est la
deuxième partie de la phrase qui
comporte l'indication de ce qu'il va
faire la première partie
faisant partie de son habituelle
concession c'est à dire oui j'ai changé
je suis mieux en tous les cas cette
démission ce matin a suscité beaucoup
beaucoup d'émoi et des réactions de la
part la classe politique sur les réseaux
sociaux je vous propose de regarder ses
réactions en images
ils peuvent entièrement changé l'équipe
gouvernementale féminiser davantage
mettre des trouvailles baroque et cetera
mais puisque ils maintiennent la même
politique inégalitaire et
anti-écologique et veulent l'aggraver
les mêmes causes produiront les mêmes
effets je tiens à remercier edouard
philippe pour tout le travail qu'il a pu
accomplir comme premier ministre et je
lui souhaite un bon retour dans la ville
qui lui est si cher edouard philippe
démissionne pour un havre de paix vu ce
qui va arriver on comprend pour
l'instant les futurs prétendants font
peur schiappa taubira belloubet s'il
s'agit pour emmanuel macron de nous
dégoter un premier ministre qui met en
oeuvre la même politique libérale et
valide la réforme des retraites contre
laquelle les français se sont battus
pendant des mois
c'est pas la peine de faire
tant de bruit un faux suspense et sur le
changement de casting qui n'aura aucune
incidence avec la poursuite d'une
politique anti écolo et sociales
dépeçage de l'ambition de la convention
citoyenne réforme des retraites
ce remaniement fait du prince symbole
d'une vème république à bout de souffle
fier des 1140 saint geours d'edouard
philippe à matignon et merci à emmanuel
macron de lui avoir fait confiance
jean casanova comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à toutes ses déclarations sur
les réseaux sociaux avec cette démission
eh bien vous voyez que d'un côté on
s'enthousiasme pour edouard philippe
et de l'autre côté on n'attend guère de
changement dans la politique du
président les français d'ailleurs sont
de cet avis les trois ou quatre
dernières études d'opinion demandant si
on s'attendait à ce que le président
modifie sa politique donne entre 65 et
70% des français qui pensent qu emmanuel
macron ne change rien ne changera en
rien son orientation politique
on s'attend donc à ce qu emmanuel macron
face d'eux les manuels macron et le
premier ministre se fera donc discret
merci j'ai casanova d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant expert en stratégie en
communication passer par de nombreux
ministères
tout de suite on dirait que l'on
continue de parler de cette démission
avec julie garnier oratrice la nationale
de la france
insoumise bonjour merci de répondre à
nos questions alexis corbière de la
france insoumise déclare que ce
changement de premier ministre ne
changera rien
les mêmes causes produiront les mêmes
effets je suppose que c'est votre avis
tout simplement parce qu'ils emmanuel
macron a déjà donné la feuille de route
il a déjà annoncé que la rentrée serait
difficile il a déjà annoncé qu'il ne
reviendrait pas sur la réforme des
retraites il a déjà annoncé que la
réforme du chômage serait poursuivi il a
déjà annoncé qu'il voulait revenir sur
les 35 heures ou jours alors on passait
très bien
il nous dit qu'on va avoir une une
rentrée difficile
donc voilà tout est dit vous parlez de
la réforme des retraites il annonçant ce
matin dans la presse quotidienne
régionale qui va y avoir de nouvelles
concertations avec les partenaires
sociaux même si le le projet n'est pas
abandonné 1
oui bien sûr je vous l'avais dit toute
façon c'est très bien des recueils
trajectoire est une vraie ce on sait
très bien que la vraie guerre va
commencer à la rentrée
c'est une guerre qui sera mené contre
les travailleurs contre les classes
populaires on sait très bien ce qu'il
veut faire
on n'est absolument pas dupes de ce
remaniement que juste de la
communication et de la vie politique
dont franchement on n'a pas vraiment
besoin
surtout quand on a un taux d'abstention
si élevé je crois que les français
attendent autre chose est sûre tous sont
inquiets ils sont inquiets parce qu'il
voit qu'il ya une grande vague de
licenciements qui se prépare qui est
déjà opérationnel et j'ai d'ailleurs une
pensée aujourd'hui pour tous les
salariés d'air france qui apprennent
qu'il ya sept mille 600 suppressions
d'emplois alors qu'on a un gouvernement
qui offre 7 milliard à la même compagnie
sans aucune contrepartie
donc voilà la politique est déjà fait ça
sera toujours la même et effectivement
comme le dit alexis corbière
les mêmes causes produiront toujours les
mêmes effets
on voit en même temps sur sur ces images
les différentes pistes a évoqué ce matin
par emmanuel macron pour la suite de son
quinquennat notamment les 35 heures
il espère que la france ne soit pas l'un
des pays d'europe où l'on travaille le
moins longtemps notamment vous avez
parlé de cela
j'aimerais revenir sur le faite vous
disais que les français souhaitent un
changement mais comment expliquer alors
que selon un sondage est là-bas parus
ces derniers temps 57% des français
souhaité qu' edouard philippe reste à
matignon même si 52% des français selon
ce même sondage souhaitait un changement
de cap c'est assez paradoxal non oui
c'est paradoxal et ça montre bien qu'on
est en pleine crise et que on a besoin
de plus de démocratie
aujourd'hui on sent que le peuple est
écarté et des canaris contraire et
donnait finalement emmanuel macron ne
fait que ce qu'il entend on voit avec la
convention citoyenne qui l'avait déjà je
vous rappelait appelé à dire qu'il n'y
aurait aucun filtre que elle pourrait
proposer tout ce qu'elle voudrait et on
voit déjà que eh ben elle est dépassée
et que tout les dires les mesures les
plus ambitieuses sont déjà mises de côté
donc les avis contraire il se rend il
les balaye les enterre on voit aussi
avec les soignants qui pendant
confinement devait être applaudi et a
été même applaudi par les députés en
marche
l'hypocrisie est aujourd'hui dévoilée
puisque les soignants eux aussi sont
écartés et me et n'ont que des
cacahuètes et rien de plus
et massa à chaque fois la même chose et
je crois que aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'une vraie démocratie on a besoin d'une
politique qui doit se remettre en
question et au problème c'est que
emmanuel macron n'est pas capable de se
remettre en question on en a besoin on a
besoin de se dire est ce que la
croissance est ce que le modèle qu'on
nous vend est ce que le marché où tout
s'échange et tout se vend et le bon
modèle et où est ce qu'il ne faut pas
plutôt aller vers autre chose
on voit qu'on est effectivement
récession c'est le temps de questionner
notre système il est urgent de se
questionner parce que devant nous on a
une crise écologique et c'est pas une
suggestion c'est une mais obligé de
dossiers de s'y confronter c'est pas des
petites mesurettes qui vont nous faire
changer le cas il faut qu'on change de
cap il faut qu'on s'interroge
profondément et malheureusement emmanuel
macron on est incapable justement vous
parlez de
de l'écologie à une vague verte aux
dernières municipales
est ce qu'il ya un profil écologistes à
matignon est envisageable que
qu'est ce que la france insoumise
penserait de cela par exemple je dis
n'importe quoi c'est pascal canfin était
premier premier ministre dans l'écologie
il y a deux choses il y avait que je
faisais d'écologistes qui disent que le
marché est totalement compatible avec
l'écologie
et il y en a d'autres qui disent que non
il faut sortir de ça je pense que la
ligne
elle est là pascal canfin on sait très
bien de quel côté il est et l'écologie
pour lui c'est du jardinage rien plus de
laurence tubiana légalement qui
circulent régulièrement
qu'en pensez vous c'est pareil ce qu'on
pense c'est qu'il faut vraiment ce qu'on
a proposé à la france un soumises pour
être très concret c'est la règle verte
la règle verte c'est de dire on peut pas
prendre plus à la nature que ce qu'elle
est en capacité de régénérer ça veut
dire que toutes les activités doit être
vue sous ce prisme
tout est donc quand on voit ça aime on
voit qu'on peut pas signer un certain
quand on prend ça on voit que on peut
pas prolonger le glyphosate quand on
voit ça on peut on peut pas accorder
d'aidé d exploitation à la montagne d'or
en guyane un bref vous voyez que quand
on met cette règle cela règle verte au
dessus de tout vous voyez bien qu'à la
fonte d'un soumises et plus légitime en
terme d'écologie qu'europe écologie les
verts par exemple
non je pense que l'écologie c'est un
profond changement de système et que là
dedans il y a des tartuffes qui pensent
que le marché est compatible avec
l'écologie et qui en a d'autres qui sont
prêts à revoir complètement le logiciel
parce qu'il n'ya que en revoyant
complètement de logiciels qu'on pourra
vraiment faire de l'écologie en dehors
de ça c'est du jardinage
qu'est ce que vous attendez du prochain
remaniement ministériel en terme général
puisque on a beaucoup parlé de d'edouard
philippe mais c'est la démission du
gouvernement ce qui implique donc des
portefeuilles ministériels qui vont être
vacant on pense notamment à christophe
castaner à l'intérieur qu'est ce que
vous attendez à ce que vous vous auriez
des noms à citer si par exemple vous
vous seriez appelé ce que vous diriez
oui et que feriez vous je pense que vous
savez très bien que personne de la
france soit soumise n'acceptera quoi que
ce soit et manuel da cruz
n'essaiera même pas des gars parce que
toute façon nous ne sommes pas du tout
dans le même logiciel que lui je pense
qu'il peut juste faire confiance à des
opportunistes et c'est tout en tout cas
moi je l'attends absolument rien de ce
remaniement
je suis lucide et je pense que les
français le sont aussi on voit comment
il a il a traité à chaque contestation
qui a été dans la rue et ça fait des
années que ça dure
malheureusement il n'y a rien à attendre
de sa part rapport à la communication de
l'elysée de matignon le fait d'annoncer
cette démission ce matin qu'est-ce que
ça traduisent selon vous bah ça traduit
surtout qu'ils n'ont pas grand chose a
commenté parce que malheureusement il ya
d'autres réalités en ce moment dans
notre pays saleh jeu j'ai fait la liste
de tous les licenciements qui sont
annoncées et je peux vous dire que c'est
terrifiant absolument terrifiant il ya
sanofi il ya bois rouillac athènes il ya
1 h 9 alinéa la halle qui compte pour
déjà quinze licenciements camaïeu celio
là on en est déjà à presque dix mille
encore renault et air france easyjet tu
nokia boeing etc la liste est tellement
longue et tout ça ça se compte en
milliers de licenciements c'est de ça
dont on devrait parler c'est ça
l'urgence c'est qu'aujourd'hui en france
on a des gens qui vont crever de faim
c'est ça on a des gens qui sont mis sur
le côté on a des et puis rien n'est fait
aussi pour nos jeunes on voit que les
fermetures de classes on se prolonger à
la rentrée c'est ça la vraie urgence
pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en parle pas
c'est ça qui devrait faire les gros
titres et par edouard philippe qui va
aux aventures de foot finalement parce
que qu'est ce qui inquiète aujourd'hui
les français ce qui les inquiète c'est
de pouvoir remplir leur frigo à la fin
du mois ce qui les inquiète c'est de ne
pas pouvoir perdre leur travail
ce qui les inquiète c'est de pouvoir en
trouver un et ils ne pourront pas ce qui
les inquiète c'est que aujourd'hui la
formation professionnelle et moi c'est
plus compliqué d'avoir accès à la
formation professionnelle que de prendre
un crédit à la banque c'est ça la
réalité aujourd'hui et malheureusement
on n'en parle pas et sait et c'est pour
ça que les il ya une vraie crise
démocratique et le remaniement là dedans
c'est une goutte d'eau ça sert à rien
c'est du vent
c'est la communication des manuels macro
merci je vais gagner c'est le mot de la
fin je rappelle que vous êtes oratrice
de la france insoumise je vous propose
d'écouter à présent alexis poulain le co
fondateur du site d'information le monde
moderne quant à cette démission qui
selon lui est impossible chemin vers une
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
de 2000 22 t clairement emmanuel macron
qui veut reprendre la main il ya cette
interview à la presse quotidienne
régionale où il donne la suite de ce
quinquennat aller plus vite plus fort
dans la réforme des retraites la réforme
de l'assurance-chômage faire face à
cette crise économique qui va faire qui
va suivre la crise sanitaire et voir
comment il peut y répondre
il veut être aux commandes il ya un
problème aujourd'hui dans l'exécutif qui
n'est pas un oeuf on l'a vu pendant
cette crise sanitaire du coronavirus
c'est la popularité d'edouard philippe
qui est bien supérieure à celle des
modèles macron parce qu'il a été vu
comme celui qui a vu le mieux géré cette
crise sanitaire
en comparaison du chef de l'état qui
paraissait déconnecté lors de ces
allocutions parfois difficile à
comprendre pour le commun des mortels
pour moi leur tour d'edouard philippe au
havre dans cette base qui est la sienne
depuis des années c'est peut-être le
début du chemin pour une candidature à
2022 candidature bien sûr d'opposition
et manuel mâcon même s'il a travaillé
avec lui ils pourraient dire voilà je ne
sais pas dans quelle position serait
monnaie le maquereau en 2022 s'il pourra
se représenter compte tenu de
l'impopularité de ce président et des
réformes qu'il entend engager avant la
fin de son quinquennat
ça pourrait être tout à fait le joker
pour la suite de pas forcément l om mais
nous refonte encore dans cette
réinvention permanente d'un centre assez
protéiforme français pour garder le
pouvoir à l'ats cette information de
marianne l'elysée pour annoncer en début
d'après midi la nomination de jean
castex au poste de premier ministre
information à prendre donc avec des
pincettes
on verra ce qui se passera ces
prochaines heures c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale consacrée à cette
démission du gouvernement d'edouard
philippe rester sur arte france
prochains invités à suivre à 13h à la
présentation ce sera mona amoud et leur
très bonne journée à tous sur un an
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]